hey what would happen if a government or
a country decided to charge zero taxes
to all the citizens what would happen to
that country let me show you what would
happen to that country if they were to
charge zero percent taxes I am right now
you see all that construction being done
look at the construction of the how many
homes they're building over there three
hundred and sixty skyscrapers built
within a five-mile radius in a place
that offers zero percent taxes and so
many of us live in so many countries
where we pay all these kinds of taxes
wondering that we're supposed to because
it's what everybody's been conditioned
to pay taxes with for many many years in
America taxes tax code started in 1913
and what if what if let's just say what
if instead of paying taxes what if we
paid for whatever natural resources that
country offered but we paid a higher
price for it meaning what if gas wasn't
four dollars a gallon it was fifteen
dollars a gallon but you paid zero
income taxes zero sales taxes and you
just paid extra for things that use what
if you wanted to build a home out of
water you have to pay permits what if
you had to pay permits for things that
you decided to use and buy rather than
just taxes for the heck of it what if
everything that we paid for was based on
things that you use that you pay for
instead of maybe somebody else uses that
you pay for that would be pretty
interesting right that's what Dubai
decided to do so my wife says you know
how are they able to build all these
buildings here I said the government
didn't build a single building all these
buildings are built by day a you know by
the by the by by people all these
buildings are built by people who decide
to start their own business people who
decide to build their own homes P
decided to build a big building build a
hotel corporations 0% taxes in Dubai and
they're getting millions and millions of
visitors from around the world coming
here and deciding to build here and
that's just one angle I just showed you
Borgia a lot up is on the other side 15
minutes away from here that's a whole
different structure on what they're
building that's just one angle I showed
you here but it would be interesting you
know in the book Atlas Shrugged they
decide to build a city a place what if
there was a place where all the
innovators showed up what if there was a
place where all the creative people who
wanted to create jobs and create
businesses and have low regulation and
have low control and have low PC police
running around telling you what to say
what not to say and be careful to use
that word because if you do you gonna be
crucified by the media what if there was
a place that was all about those who
were innovators got together and decided
to build and they charge you no taxes
well I think there is a place like that
in the world it's called Dubai that's
the closest thing to this story of Atlas
Shrugged you can think about building a
community of pioneers entrepreneurs who
come here and they say go build you
won't have to pay anything you'll have
to pay permits you'll have to pay
certain they're thinking about raising
the gas prices over here I think that
makes sense but no taxes what would a
place like that be it would be called
Dubai and I think sometimes instead of
just sitting there saying well I have to
pay taxes because it's the right thing
to do I have to pay taxes no we have to
pay taxes because you know the law
states that we have to but we can start
shifting our mindset when it comes down
to voting how to start thinking about
voting on everything being about raising
taxes on everybody and what it does
people all over the world want to come
and work in Dubai just so you know these
hotels have created hundreds of
thousands of jobs of people from Europe
that want to work here from America
that'll work in you I can't tell you how
many Americans are working here at
Atlantis how many Americans are working
here and Dubai because they just said
I'm gonna come and work over here
because it doesn't matter what part of
the world you create jobs people from
all over the world will
I want to work for a company that's
creating jobs and that's what's
happening here in Dubai
think about it thirty years ago there
was nothing in Dubai nothing in Dubai
there was the first building the
gentleman was telling me was built in
1980 was the first structure that they
were building and they were working on
the World Trade Center and now I mean
you can't look around it without seeing
a skyscraper this is what happens when
you allow capitalism to do its work and
you don't get in the way of innovators
they're able to build a powerful city
where the world wants to come and visit
and that's what happened to Dubai and
it's a it's a interesting place today
capitalism is a curse word you used the
word capitalism it's a bad word nowadays
if you use the word capitalism all you
care about is money all you care about
is all this other stuff but I wonder
what would happen if we took the
capitalists out I wonder what jobs would
be created by would it be created by
socialists communists I don't know about
that I think jobs are created by
capitalists who go out there and decide
to create an opportunity and take the
heat from everybody that says all they
care about is money but then all the
people that say all that person cares
about his money work for capitalists so
if we take the capitalist out
unemployment would be a hundred percent
that's what it would because the
government wouldn't have any money to
create any job so look the reality is my
message is very simple every time a bill
comes out every time the left or the
right or the middle comes out with a way
to decide to sell us on how great it is
to raise taxes question it question it
you being left alone is much better to
you than you having to pay taxes for
some other way to raise taxes for you me
or boss for anybody else out there it
doesn't make any sense to do it if
you're an entrepreneur it hurts
everybody and eventually the innovators
come to place like goodbye so instead of
singing a song that starship saying many
years ago from you know the song we
build this city we built this city on a
rock and roll you remember that song
forget about my voice but remember that
song you know what Dubai song is here's
how to buy sings it we built this city
we built this city with no taxes that's
to buy what would happen if there were
no taxes this is what would happen
stay tuned for more videos